it's a lot of it was trying new things
so I'm more of like I would rather go in
a
you know I'd rather jump off a bridge
and some something something silly like
well something adventurous and
adrenaline pump like that whereas
Oliver's a bit more he'd rather go it's
like buying a nice food places and um
yeah more culture and uh the guest would
normally be somewhere in between so we
kind of want to show that you could go
away into a new place but actually
if you're with someone else you do
things which you wouldn't necessarily do
before and that may be something that
may be the highlight of your trip right
necessarily realize that would be it
it's kind of like a married couple in a
lot of ways you got to compromise
because you know Oliver likes to do his
thing you want to do your thing so
you're like all right well go to your
thing your art gallery we'll check out
some art and then we're gonna go
skydiving you cool with that and you
kind of work it out there I mean is that
sort of the way it works yeah yeah kind
of I mean we were the way the concepts
came about
um a couple of years ago I remember
James my we had uh appeared at a
convention in Colorado
and had a really great weekend with
everyone there I think it was like the
Fourth of July weekend so it was a big
big weekend type festivity type thing
and afterwards James needs Powell um
wanted to go
um while water rafting and they were
climbing to mountains and stuff and I
was I was going to try we were doing
we were going to do the the 14ers we're
going to do a load of the 14 000 feet
mountains around the Rockies in Colorado
and white water rafting and all that
kind of stuff
so they were they were down to do that
and I was about
I don't know if you were there actually
at that convention when we were there I
kind of think I was because I remember I
just remember being in this car on the
way to the airport with you guys once
and you were telling me about it is that
right yeah yeah because we we just I
remember like literally about a day the
day before I flew out I was in a pretty
gnarly car accident
and in hindsight shouldn't have gone but
anyway that's a different story and I
was like after the after the show I was
like oh god well I won't do the white
water rafting or anything like that but
I'll come I'll come down
it's just south of Colorado Springs so
ended up doing the monitoring class
which was just not fun it's like
literally climbing Railway created for
yeah it's one of those things when you
do it you're like okay this is great but
I don't know how people do it more than
once that was the way I perceived you
know I look over and James actually does
it
it's literally a it's literally a
a mile up
like straight up and it's at times it
gets to like 80 gradient so you're
pretty much scrambling up there
uh ladder altitude obviously because
you're in Colorado I remember doing that
and just thinking so I don't know if
that's to do with because I've got like
really bug in my neck before I had like
you know three broken ribs or something
but if I I don't want to do this again
I've done that and um and then
afterwards James I booked the hotel down
the road and we just come from what they
say we've been in been in Denver saying
a nice hotel met loads of nice people
and we were literally staying in this
Motel
um like side of the road job like 19
cash for the place to stay there
overnight you know the type of place
where you've got to move the closet in
front of the door when you go to sleep
oh yeah
and I was thinking
I know people think we're you obviously
look the same but we're definitely
different when it comes to this because
this would not have been the type of
place I would have I would want to stay
you know it's a book do you remember the
hotel though
yeah for all the wrong reasons I don't
think do you remember that one in Denver
the nice one in Denver you don't
remember too much but you remember that
one so that's the memory foreign